good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight want to hear an amazing
story it has the benefit of being both
true and illuminating here it is
in 1851 a man called samuel cartwright
came up with a fairly
sophisticated scientific explanation for
why so many slaves were running away
from plantations
in the american south these fugitive
slaves cartwright explained were
suffering from a
medical disorder it was called
drapedomania
it was a syndrome characterized by an
uncontrollable or
insane impulsion to wander
so that was the problem it wasn't they
disliked being enslaved
or yearned for freedom and basic
humanity no no no
the problem according to samuel
cartwright was that black people as a
group were inherently defective they
were
drapedomaniacs they were always running
away
that's what he said 107 years later it
is embarrassing to repeat something this
stupid
out loud it's so obviously insane but
here's what you should know
drapedomania was taken very seriously at
the time and so was samuel cartwright
cartwright was not a fringe character
at all he was a nationally prominent
physician a former high-ranking army
officer from fairfax virginia he went to
penn medical school
samuel cartwright was a credentialed man
of science who commanded the respect of
the country
50 years after the civil war one of this
nation's leading medical dictionaries
continued to maintain an entry
for drapedomania so in retrospect of
course we would call samuel cartwright a
bigot which he undoubtedly was
but he was also more than that
cartwright was a practitioner of
something called
scientific racism scientific racism is
deeper than simple prejudice
it is the use of science to justify the
dominance of one group over another
group
scientific racism has a history as long
as science simply because the impulse to
dominate
is inherent to human nature so it's not
really about
color though it's called racism instead
it's about power
martin luther king wrote eloquently
about this so did dr seuss by the way
you might want to take a look at what
they wrote assuming you can still buy
their books
the point is scientific racism never
actually went away
it's still with us no one talks about
drapedomania anymore
instead are medical professionals and
law professors and military leaders and
politicians and cable news hosts
have identified a new disorder they
claim explains everything bad
it's called whiteness in the
universities it has become an article of
faith
that we're not for the indelible stain
of whiteness america could be a utopia
only whiteness stands in the way that's
why we must abolish it
as harvard magazine put it abolish the
white race
only then can we be happy lots of people
seem to believe this they're not
all bad people just as not everyone who
believed in samuel cartwright in the
1850s
was evil some people are just gullible
they're looking for meaning in their
lives
if you hand them a unified theory of
everything
some percentage of them are going to buy
at wholesale they were nice people at
jonestown in guyana
they just didn't know any better it's
their leaders
that you wonder about they do know
better or they should
and when they talk about this new
iteration of scientific racism when they
talk about
whiteness they sound very much like
old-fashioned bigots
take this guy for example his name is
eric michael dyson he's a tenured
professor at some stupid college or
other
he lives in a rich almost exclusively
white neighborhood he goes on television
a lot
watch him as he talks about race and ask
yourself honestly if he sounds any
different at all from say bull connor or
david duke
he doesn't only the colors have changed
here he is
in speaking about you know the maggots
i'm sorry the magga um that
is so corrosive in this you know
political
uh moment and we have stood by to see
mediocre
mealy-mouthed snowflake white men
who are incapable of taking critique who
are willing to dole out
infamous repudiations of the humanity of
the other
and yet they call us snowflakes and they
are the biggest flakes of snow
to hit the earth they are incapable of
criticism
they are incapable of tolerating
difference they're scared of oh my god
critical race theory is going to kill
your mother
and they don't even know they're not
critical they have no race
and they don't understand theory
white men they're the problem you hear
that so often
that you don't pause to consider what a
change this is
it used to be only a few years ago that
the one thing you couldn't do
in america was attack people in public
on the basis of the race
i don't like that group because of their
skin color let's hurt them
you couldn't say that it was the one
unacceptable thing and for very good
reason
you cannot maintain a multi-racial
democracy unless people of
every color have exactly the same rights
and responsibilities under the law and
are considered of precisely the same
moral value
under god you have to have that that's
the most basic prerequisite for a
multi-racial democracy
all lives have to matter or it cannot
work
it's pretty clear that our leadership
class for whatever reason doesn't want
it to work
obviously they don't look at what
they're doing when you hear people
ascribe blood guilt to a specific racial
group when you hear them talk about the
sin of whiteness
what you're watching is the death of our
future as a country
we can't live in a nation of warring
tribes we know very well what that looks
like
because it's the history of the world
it's miserable
and vicious and bloody we can't allow
that
most americans of all colors on some
level understand this they don't always
have the words to articulate it but they
know it
when their kids come home with from
school with assignments to suggest that
all races are not in fact equal
that some races are guilty and some are
innocent that some groups are
oppressors inherently and others are
inherently oppressed
in the universities this is called
critical race theory so that's the term
that most people go with
critical race theory that's what we so
often debate on television that's a clip
we just showed you
but critical race theory is an
inaccurate way to describe what's
happening
like so much academic jargon the phrase
critical race theory doesn't mean
anything
it obscures rather than illuminates it
is designed
that way it is designed to confuse you
what's happening in our schools that our
military and our government is both
simpler and easier to recognize than
that
it's not critical race theory it's
racism
not neo-racism or reverse racism those
are meaningless terms
it is race hate it is peddled by the
people in charge in the hope that it
will make them more powerful that's all
it is
we haven't said that often enough or
clearly enough
and because we haven't because we've
been tied up in some pointless debate
about a concept that nobody can actually
define
the race hate and that's what it is has
oozed from the universities
and it has infected the entire country
including at the very highest levels
mark milley is the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff he didn't get that job
because he's brilliant or because he's
brave
or because the people who know him
respect him he is not
and they definitely don't milly got the
job because he is
obsequious he knows who to suck up to
and he's more than happy to do it
feed him a script and he will read it
here's millie yesterday the man
in charge of this nation's weapons
explained that he's working to
understand a concept
called white rage i do think it's
important actually
for those of us in uniform to be
open-minded and be widely read
and the united states military academy
is a university
and it is important that we train and we
understand
and i want to understand white rage and
i'm white and i want to understand it so
what is it that caused thousands of
people to assault
this building and try to overturn the
constitution of the united states of
america what caused that
i want to find that out i want to
maintain an open mind here and i do want
to analyze it it's
important that we understand that
because our soldiers sailors airmen
marines and guardians
they come from the american people so it
is important that the leaders
now and in the future do understand it
hard to believe that man wears a uniform
he's that unimpressive notice he never
defined white rage and we should know
what it is what is white rage
well like drape domania it's one of
those diseases that only affects people
with certain melanin levels it's a race
specific
illness that's what mark milley has
learned from reading about it
that's why he's making his soldiers read
about it too they need to know
watch i've read miles say tongue i've
read
i've read karl marx i've read lenin that
doesn't make me a communist
so what is wrong with understanding
having some situational understanding
about the country for which we are here
to defend
and i personally find it offensive that
we are accusing
the united states military our general
officers our commission non-commissioned
officers
of being quote woke
[Laughter]
he's not just a pig he's stupid so mark
milly reads
mao to understand maoism he reads
communist to understand communism
but it's interesting that he doesn't
read white supremacists to understand
white supremacy
why not go to the source well because
mark milley would be fired
instantly if he read those books and
getting fired is
the one thing he doesn't want so he
reads about white rage as if it's
totally real it's a medical condition
and by the way since it's a medical
condition at what age can you catch
white rage by the way
most of us assume that our two-year-olds
were just teething now we know it's
their whiteness that's making them so
angry thanks mark millie
we appreciate your contribution to our
generation's scientific racism
by the way have you read anything
recently about winning wars apparently
not
we could go on and on and on pundit
after senator after professor after
general
each one of them spewing race hate
whiteness white rage dressed up as some
new academic theory
we certainly have the tape will spare
you because you've seen it it's
everywhere the question is and this is
the question that we should be
meditating on
day in and day out is how do we get out
of this vortex this cycle before it's
too late
how do we save this country before we
become rwanda
what should we be teaching our children
so they can live in the country that you
want to live in
a country full of many different kinds
of people many different
but who actually like each other who are
happy to work together
who are united ultimately by the core
fact which is they're all americans
that is the question hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else